Songwriting is
tension and release.
You set up an
expectation, and then you
make people wait just a second--
and then you fulfill
the expectation.
[MUSIC PLAYING - ST. VINCENT,
"FEAR THE FUTURE"]
Your best tool in the
world is your ears.
Da da da da dee dee
dee dee dee dee dee.
If you have ears and ideas,
you can make anything happen.
As an artist, you will
never be satisfied.
The trick is to
take something good
and bludgeon it till it's great,
or set it aside and refine,
refine, refine, refine, refine.
In this MasterClass, I
want to share with you guys
some performance tips, some
songwriting tips, some studio
tips.
We're going to take
my song "Savior"
and walk through every step
of the songwriting process.
You can hear how it's doing a
kind of rhythm, [SINGS RHYTHM]
to add texture.
The first lyric really ought
to be compelling enough
for people to go, wait, what?
(SINGING) You dress
me up, please.
Got that?
Are Annie Clark and St.
Vincent the same thing?
Honestly, you'd have to ask her.
I came up with the
moniker St. Vincent
so that I could
have the flexibility
to be any number of things.
I recorded a lot of my first
album in my childhood bedroom,
sitting at the
computer like this.
[TYPING]
I'm going to play the audio.
It's so embarrassing.
Oh god.
Make shame your friend.
Because there's no way to get
good at something without being
bad at it first.
Just keep going, because
everybody feels weird
sometimes.
Everybody feels like
they don't fit in,
but you can speak to that
in a way that's real.
You can move the needle in
a more empathetic direction
for the world.
I'm St. Vincent,
and I'm Annie Clark,
and this is my MasterClass.